you
an inguinal hernia is a condition where
abdominal contents such as the intestine
bulged through a weakness in an area of
the groin called the inguinal canal as
the intestine pushes through this
weakness a hernia sac made from tissue
lining the inside of the abdomen called
the peritoneum surrounds it the
intestine may become trapped or
incarcerated inside the hernia sac over
time its blood supply may be cut off
leading to strangulation where the
tissue inside the hernia sac dies
a totally extra peritoneal laparoscopic
inguinal hernia repair requires only
small keyhole incisions into the abdomen
known as ports to reach the hernia the
surgeon will insert a tube called a
trocar through a port located just below
your navel or umbilicus this instrument
will be used to separate the inner
abdominal wall from the peritoneum then
a balloon surrounding the instrument
will be inflated to create a space for
the surgeon to work next your surgeon
will insert the laparoscope through the
umbilical port images from its camera
will be transmitted to a video monitor
in the operating room once the working
space is created two additional trocars
will be inserted the surgeon will pass
surgical instruments through them these
instruments will be used to separate
attachments to the hernia sack and
gently pull it out of the inguinal canal
and back into the abdomen to prevent
anything from slipping back through the
opening the surgeon will place a piece
of mesh over it and tack it in place
the incisions will be closed with
sutures
followed by skin glue or skin closure
tape if there are complications with
your laparoscopic procedure your surgeon
will switch to an open procedure with a
larger incision